their quarantine behind them passengers
from the diamond princess have been
disembarking in their hundreds many of
them taken by bus to the middle of
Yokohama with mixed emotions about their
shared ordeal every day I would worry
that I was going to test positive when
the number of people getting infected
spiked we knew there were secondary
infections so I was afraid to leave my
cabinet the crew members did very well
so I was grateful to them the passengers
were then allowed to continue their
journeys home sharing public transport
with fellow Japanese who have mixed
emotions of their own I feel so sorry
for them it's a good idea to release
them they were going to get sick foreign
countries say their quarantine the
people for a certain time so I want
Japan to do the same the confirmed
deaths of two elderly passengers have
raised concerns for those still on board
and for foreign governments who are
still arranging to fly home their
citizens but insisting they undergo
further quarantine still Japan is
standing by its decision to end the
quarantine of the cruise ship you win to
you the ship does not compare to a
hospital we are working there with
temporary measures we have a basic
standard but various issues there that
pointed out everyday we keep correcting
these issues on a daily basis with cases
being reported across Japan this
outbreak is causing increased disruption
public events have been scaled back or
canceled including an annual birthday
celebration for the Emperor and there
are growing fears if this goes on about
the possible impact on the upcoming
Summer Olympics in Tokyo
a passing cruise liner sounds its horn
in a show of support for the diamond
princess for Japan finally resolving
this crisis is a priority and it knows
the world is watching it has to be borne
in mind that of all the people who have
been confirmed to be carrying the virus
who have been infected a good number of
them have had very mild symptoms or
indeed haven't shown any symptoms of
cough or fever at all but it's also
worth bearing in mind that with the
spread of the disease throughout this
ship of all of the thousands of people
who came on board all of those weeks ago
now roughly around one in six despite
all of the precautions despite the
quarantine have gradually been infected
which is a pretty grim ratio Rob many
thanks let's talk now to mary-louise
McLaws she's a World Health Organization
advisor and a professor of epidemiology
at the University of New South Wales she
joins us from Sydney welcome to the news
out here on al-jazeera we're talking now
about South Korea China Japan at the
front line of the fight against the
corona virus what do you make of how the
authorities in those countries are
handling this look at the last meeting
that we had face to face meeting for the
roadmap for current virus we were
reminded to always include ethics about
anything that we do be in the
epidemiology the infection control
vaccines etc and what concerns me is
that as an epidemiologist we really
value quarantining it's a very effective
method of trying to put a halt to an
outbreak however it has to be done very
ethically and very safely and you don't
put a lot of susceptible people together
and hope that they're going to remain
uninfected without an awful lot of
Education of those susceptibles and also
without very very rigorous cleaning of
high-touch areas so I'm concerned about
why one in six as you've reported have
acquired covent 19 while they were under
quarantine now some of them may have
been incubating before just before they
were quarantined however a lot of them
may not have been so really we we really
can't got people in quarantine unless we
keep them safe why is it therefore if
you've got that right and of course you
have why is it therefore that the
authorities are going so far but not
going further it seems to me that what
you're actually doing then is turning
the ship into a massive breeding chamber
and if the authorities in Beijing for
example or South Korea are telling
people to self quarantine with their
families then you're turning their
apartments or their houses into a big
petri dish look it's very difficult
because humans like the contact of other
human beings so it's very difficult to
put them in quarantine by themselves and
some families do need to be together
the other problem is so I'm standing
very critical of the ship and certainly
I would be very concerned about their
their cleaning methods they're teaching
them how to use a mask properly with
clean hands how to take the mask off and
have a new mask every time they have to
wear a mask and to keep the passageways
which are sometimes a little stuffy for
internal cabins they have to be all very
clean but when we ask people to stay at
home it's it's probably the kindest
place because they're very familiar
there but we still need to teach them
how to disinfect and and rigorously
clean bathrooms and high-touch
areas in case one of them is incubating
it now one of your reporters mentioned
that the majority cases are mild and
that's what is coming out from the data
of China that
eighty percent a mild but what's also
coming out recently is that the period
of infectivity seems to be much sooner
than it wasn't SARS
so people are mild but also infectious
very early on so it could also be a
driver
for a lot of the infection of either
clusters in families or clusters on
ships as well
you mentioned SARS there in effect it
was mother nature that did for SARS
because SARS as a virus didn't like the
way the weather developed around and in
those SARS related countries could this
happen could that happen with the corona
virus yes I was very fortunate to look
at the data and and find out what was
going on with sighs both in Beijing and
in Hong Kong and both countries did an
amazing job trying to put in place
infection control measures but mother
nature also played a part
so after SARS a scientist did a study in
a laboratory to find that son didn't
much like a warmer weather or increased
humidity so as soon as it started become
May in 2003 the numbers started dropping
so it could have been a combination of
both excellent infection control but
also mother nature helping as well so
although I don't want to wish for any
climate change issue happening in China
one really hopes that the temp the
temperature will start to increase so
that they can be helped along with this
massive challenge that they have okay
mary louise McLaws there in australia
thank you very much